[Music]
i think being able to
um especially being in cabinet i think
is is being able to
see the change and actually having an
impact on decisions that are going on
throughout the district and through
people's lives really the sort of case
work with the families locally because
particularly in my ward
we've got a lot of problems and it's
really nice to feel you're making a
difference in people's lives we
we love getting involved with the
community as well as
as well as the council meetings and
things like that but mainly the area
and the people that are in it
just trying really making the difference
listening
i
i really like policy um because i think
you can get into the nitty-gritty of of
making a fundamental difference for a
long time it might just seem uh people
don't really notice it because it's not
necessarily a physical thing it's not
like a play park it's not anything like
that but um you can change like the way
that people engage with the council or
how the council approaches stuff just
helping case work helping people but i
just like helping people really
so it sounds very cliched but it's very
rewarding to help people it's always
nice when you you are actually able to
get a a
successful outcome in in case work and
that's that's always the the nice thing
is actually being able to the end of the
day saying i've helped that individual
get into a house or i've helped that
individual
sort something with their child out or
something along those lines and it's
it's that kind of nice reward that you
being able to help your community out
essentially
[Music]